un petit chat abandonné émeutes ont
alors donné son programme ça arrive tous
les jours je vous en prie vous comprenez
pas je suis perdu c'est pas notre
problème c'est propriété interdite va
découvrir un univers mystérieux
le petit truc ce doublé voilà tu es
comme le tout peu comme nous j'ai trouvé
les enfants les gemmois présentait le
nouveau membre de notre trou on va pas
te laisser l'embobiner à coups de
millions yahoo et prendre notre place
mais un danger plane sur leur maison de
lorraine toi et moi pareil au sérieux ce
rang de ta maison de contrat qui
laissait d'armagh et l'ancêtre qui
pourrait aussi nous causer de gros
ennuis stone il veut vendre le manoir en
eau pure haine c'est pas là résultat on
sera tous que je suis dehors alors la
pile pour ceux des femmes touchent aussi
commentaire
justement préparez vous à vivre une
aventure enchanté
non
depuis des mois
oh non
le manoir magique si jamais il y en a un
qui veut me filer un coup de main je dis
pas mort au cinéma le 25 décembre en 3d
et en 2d